as of midnight last night alberta has
lifted basically all of the remaining
public health restrictions that were in
place
the sense of deja vu is strong because
alberta has been here before
and of course things then didn't go so
well under the weight of the delta wave
and a summer free of restrictions
alberta's intensive care units nearly
collapsed in late july early august of
2021
we had 90 patients in hospital with
covet and 19 in the icu
now we currently have over approximately
1200 people in hospital in the 60s in
the icu still dr daniel gregson does not
believe the open for spring plan will
result in the same stress though he does
expect hospital numbers will climb if
you look what's going on in denmark
which is one of the countries
our government is allowing for removing
restrictions they are they have gone
their their hospital rates per million
have have gone up by about 25 30 in the
last two weeks my son is uh we call it
medically complex for families like the
watanabes this is an anxious time a
coveted infection for their little boy
could lead to a lengthy hospital stay i
feel defeated i feel completely defeated
i don't know what else we can do i'm
sure we will wear masks for
as long as we
feel comfortable doing it alberta is
also planning to strip municipalities of
the power to put their own public health
rules in place
accusing cities of playing politics i
would think that the premier is going to
be more influenced by politics than
municipalities given that they have just
been re-elected or elected whereas he is
facing division with his own party a
leadership review and an upcoming
election there is a lot at stake with
little patience left for missteps after
two years and five punishing waves of
this pandemic heather urex west global
news calgary